hi i'm christine goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
president trump and democratic
presidential nominee joe biden
facing off on the debate stage in
cleveland what were the biggest
moments and did either candidate move
the needle
fox news radio's national correspondent
jared halpern and fox news radio's
political analyst josh crushauer
recapped the first presidential debate
with kyle kondik managing editor of
salvador's crystal ball at the
university of virginia's center for
politics
democrats and republicans have been
divided over the size and scope
of a new coronavirus stimulus package
mark zandi chief economist for moody's
analytics
discusses the nation's economic recovery
and how much relief he thinks is needed
to help americans cope amid the pandemic
plus commentary by fox news contributor
and fox nation host rachel campos-duffy
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm greg jarrett i'm shannon breme i'm
steve doocy
and this is the fox news rundown
wednesday september 30th 2020
i'm jared halpern president trump and
joe biden finally face off in a
fiery first debate so did it change any
voters minds
i don't necessarily know if a lot of
mines were changed but but it seemed
like the reaction of biden was a little
more positive than that of trump
i'm dave anthony since the economy was
an issue in the debate
we will go in depth the recession's over
it was short
two months march april very severe
obviously we lost 22 million jobs in
that
period and so the economy is recovering
but slow
going and there's one thing economist
mark zandy tells us for october
that could really help or hurt the
president
and i'm rachel campos-duffy i've got the
final word
on the fox news rundown
[Music]
insults and interruptions overshadowed
much of the first debate between
president trump and former vice
president joe biden
fox news sunday host chris wallace
moderated the
90-minute session a job that at times
took on the role of
referee
why should i be different than the two
of you biden told president trump to
shut up you get the final word well it's
hard to get any word in with this clown
the president questioned biden's
intelligence did you use the word smart
so you said you went to delaware state
but you forgot the name of your college
you didn't go to delaware state you
graduated
either the lowest or almost the lowest
in your class don't ever use the word
smart with me
don't ever use that word oh give me your
because you know what there's nothing
smart about you joe the debate did
feature questions that are
top of mind for voters the economy in
the corona virus race relations and
violence in city streets
and whether both candidates are prepared
to accept the results of the november
third election
in terms of whether or not when the
votes are counted and they're all
counted
that will be accepted if i win that will
be accepted if i lose that'll be
accepted i hope it's going to be a fair
election if it's a fair election
i am 100 on board but if i see tens of
thousands of ballots being manipulated
i can't go along with that and i'll tell
you what from a common sense does that
mean you're going to tell your other
people
it means you have a fraudulent election
but were any minds changed did swing
voters and undecideds find a clarifying
message
in all of it i think it's important to
remember that uh
there aren't that many undecided voters
fox news radio political analyst josh
krasauer and i
discussed that and where these campaigns
go next with
kyle kondik the editor of sabato's
crystal ball at the university of
virginia's
center for politics some of the polling
we saw
before the debate suggests that i think
cbs yougov suggested that only
six percent of those who were actually
planning to watch the debate
said they were watching because they
hadn't made up their mind and were
looking for some more information
there was some other polling suggesting
that the percentage of people
who said that the debate was going to
make a difference in their vote was
lower than in both 2012 and 2016. so
you know obviously it was a it was an
explosive and potentially unprecedented
kind of debate
but i think it's worth keeping in
context that in this particular election
there aren't that many undecided folks
uh
i i saw some details from you know frank
luntz does his his focus groups and
uh it seemed like from what i could tell
from what was coming out of those focus
groups that
um i don't necessarily know if a lot of
mines were changed but but it seemed
like the reaction of biden was a little
more positive than that of trump
um there was a snap poll from yougov of
debate watchers i think
48 percent said said biden won
41 said trump won which is basically the
size of trump of biden's national lead
right now
a lot of people who tune into these
things just gotta tune in to cheer for
their respective side so
um you know it's a long way of saying
that that you know it's hard to know how
folks might react to it but
um one other point is that if if part of
trump's problem is that
people view his his uh presidency as
being kind of exhausting and chaotic
you know instigating this chaotic and
exhausting debate
probably doesn't help him with that
problem
let's talk about the the tenor and tone
of this debate because i think to your
point uh that
is going to overwhelm some of the
substance uh
and the policy uh answers in this debate
and i'm just curious as somebody who
watches a lot of debates and i know you
watch not just presidential debates but
senate debates and
uh house races and and everything
was this different than what we have
seen this
election cycle in in other races
i mean there's this there's this guy
running in maine named max lynn
who is like a conservative alternative
in the senate race who's been
pretty outrageous but uh i don't know if
it necessarily compares
compares to this i personally thought
that this was maybe maybe i've just sort
of
time has sort of dulled the memories of
it but i really thought that this was
kind of like a more crazy out-of-control
debate than any of the three from from
2016.
um and i think the reaction to it also
suggested that a lot of the
kind of the commentators sort of felt
that way but again maybe maybe we've
just maybe we've just sort of
lost track of of what happened in uh
in in in in 2016 but you know clearly
the president
wanted to kind of get inside biden's
head sort of forced biden to make some
sort of big mistake because
the whole um you know i think the the
trump campaign's messaging has basically
been that hey
biden is so old and clueless that he you
know he he's not up to running the
country
and i think the idea was maybe to to
force biden into some sort of mistake by
constantly interrupting him but
i don't think biden made any sort of
huge mistake i don't necessarily
think that biden was particularly sharp
i think he was much better the last time
we saw him in a one-on-one debate which
was against bernie sanders
back in march but i thought biden was
basically fine
and if the idea was for for trump to
force him into some sort of huge error i
don't necessarily think that he did
hey kyle it's uh josh and you've written
the book literally
on ohio and its politics and ohio was
was a fascinating state in 2016 because
you had some some remarkable swings from
president obama
to to president trump from 2012 to 2016.
those swing voters in youngstown and in
cincinnati and in toledo
and in those blue collar parts of the
state
what do you think they they how how they
would react when they when they see
just a feisty aggressive um down
you know just food fight of a debate
like we saw tonight do you think that
that those blue-collar voters go in a
certain direction when they come when it
comes to debate like this
i mean look i think trump still has some
of some appeal to a lot of
to a lot of blue-collar voters in in the
sense that he is
kind of an outrageous character who kind
of you know is extremely politically
incorrect and
uh i think that he sort of they sort of
uh like the
they they like the enemies that that the
president has and i i don't think
anything really changed from that
tonight
the one thing i can't say about ohio and
i think this is true in other
in other states across the country is
that um
trump actually did fine in the suburbs
he actually did slightly better than
mitt romney did in ohio and then he
really cleaned up in kind of small town
rural areas
but from the best that i can tell from
sources on both
you know both parties that the
president's numbers in the suburbs are
way worse than
they were in 2016 in ohio and again
it's probably true in other places and
and you know if those are voters who are
kind of
turned off by trump maybe not being
presidential
or um you know again being there being
this sort of
you know all this chaos around his
administration and not being serious
enough in a very serious time
you know that that that's when i think
maybe the president's behavior tonight
doesn't really help him and
you also got to remember that you know
biden came into this debate leading
so trump's the one who needs things to
change after it i'm not necessarily sure
you know
i don't know if they will i want to ask
both of you this question and we'll
start
with you kyle uh and then josh jump in
um
what is the the moment or a couple of
moments that
are really going to resonate really
going to stick with this debate
um the whole thing is kind of a blur to
me i mean
biden did uh you know did you know tell
the president to shut up which i think
maybe maybe stands out
i'm not gonna answer the question
because you answered that because the
question is
the question is justice radical left
would you
listen who is on your list joe and uh
also
uh you know there's been a lot of
discussion about the president kind of
refusing to uh to condemn uh you know
white supremacists which has been a a
theme of his presidency
i'm willing to do anything i want to see
peace sir say it
do it say it do you want to call him
what do you want to call him give me
your name give me a white supremacy
boys stand back and stand by but i'll
tell you what
i'll tell you what somebody's got to do
something about antifa and the left
and so that's something that that again
came up in a lot of the uh
the post-debate conversation yeah i
think
i think the quote from joe biden will
you shut up man
that is gonna be the sound bite of the
debate and uh
it's a rorschach test of where the
country is i think there are a lot of
democrats and certainly biden supporters
who think that boy he really showed the
president after he's interrupting and
he's attacking so so so so
aggressively but i think you know a lot
a lot of uh republicans would look at
that and see that as a low blow from the
from the democrat and sort of a what
aboutism of sorts
that that you hear so often in in
politics these days
so i mean i i just think that was sort
of the seminal moment early in the
debate
that just showed how off the rails this
this
this whole debate ended up ended up
becoming i want to finish with this
because this is uh with the caveat that
uh
following the debate in a press call the
biden campaign
said that uh the vp will be
participating in the next two debates
the next debate is a town hall style
debate kyle
what do you expect over the next two
debates between uh president trump and
and former vice president biden
uh i mean it's it's certainly going to
be an interesting format at the town
hall it
it it often is uh and i think the
president
is going to have to really tone tone it
down because
he can't it's one thing to be going
after moderator it's another thing to be
going after
actual you know actual actual people
asking him uh
asking him questions so it may just be
that the format of the next debate
um because it's a town hall we'll sort
of we'll sort of
kind of naturally tone things down a
little bit josh yeah and i
you know i i think that number one it's
interesting that joe biden is definitely
doing the next uh
two debates that there was a little bit
of a question perhaps
among some you know analysts that maybe
he would want to back out given the way
this this debate uh transpired but
no i think that that kyle is absolutely
right that the
town hall format is a much different
dynamic and
you don't want to be quite as um
aggressive you don't want to be quite as
critical when you're trying to talk to
voters and showing empathy and showing
that you you can connect with the
average
questioner so i think that that style is
going to be a whole lot different it
may lead to a different result of course
the wild card in all of this is as
these debates are happening in this time
in between the bait kyle an awful lot of
folks are going to be
filing and casting their ballots yeah i
mean
according to uh michael mcdonald who
really tracks a lot of the
early voting trends i think i think he
added up to 1.3 million people have
voted now granted
if you expect maybe a 140 to 150 million
people maybe actually more than that who
end up voting
it's a small number but the number is
going to keep growing um and uh you know
a lot of people are going to be voting
um voting by mail and voting early in
person it seems like
um the democrat many more democrats
going to be voting that way whereas
republicans are holding back to uh
to election day i think in part because
how the president has talked about it
but you know again the clock's ticking
um the you know we've known the
president's been behind for for a while
here
there have been times where he i think
you know certain moments in the campaign
where i think he's been hoping to catch
up
you know i think his position is
probably a little bit better than it was
in in
june and july but he's still behind and
you know we'll wait and see if anything
changes after this debate although
the the way the campaign has gone so far
it's been you know
a crazy chaotic year in campaign but the
boy the numbers don't change all that
much
absolutely it has been a very stable
race according to the polls the next
debate is the vice
presidential debate that will be at the
university of utah in salt lake city
that is next week and we will all talk
to you
then
[Music]
this is rachel campos-duffy with your
fox news commentary coming up
it was a key topic in last night's
debate
and the one issue that voters in many
polls including the most recent fox
survey
give president trump the edge over joe
biden
the economy and who better can guide us
through
the coronavirus recovery no the
recession's over it was short
two months march april very severe
obviously we lost 22 million jobs in
that period mark zandy is chief
economist for moody's analytics
the economy is recovering but slow going
uh we've gotten about half the jobs we
lost
back so we're still down about 11
million jobs
and of that 11 million just for a bit of
context 6 million
or so are folks that say they're on
temporary layoff that they've been
furloughed they'll get back to work
hopefully soon the other remaining 5
million however
are on permanent layoffs so it's going
to take a good
bit of time to get those folks back to
work so this is uh this is slow going
it's a slog but
at least we're recovering yeah now we
get another jobs report on
friday what are you expecting
i expected another gain of about 700 000
jobs many of them coming in those
industries that
continue to slowly reopen restaurants
leisure hospitality transportation the
healthcare sector
um that's where we'll get the bulk of
the jobs so you know that's a good gain
but obviously slowing
if you go back in june we had a gain of
nearly
5 million jobs and we've been throttling
back ever since
and we're getting pretty close to the
point where we're not going to be able
to get many more
jobs back in those industries that got
hit hard so it's going to be
i think much tougher to get those job
gains going forward particularly if
congress administration
can't figure out a way to provide more
help to the economy then i think that's
going to be more of a headwind
for for jobs and the unemployment rate
is what still in the 8
range maybe yeah it was 8.4 in august i
i don't
expect that to change all that much but
i do expect the labor force to pick up
as well the other thing that's gone
that's happened here is that you've had
a millions of people
step out of the workforce altogether
they stop looking for work
and when you stop looking for work even
if you want a job you're not counted as
unemployed so i expect some of those
folks to start coming back in looking
for work and that'll add to the
unemployment so
net net i don't expect much of a change
in the unemployment rate
now you mentioned the recession is over
how did we determine it was just march
and april
a recession is a a broad-based uh
persistent decline in economic activity
that's the
definition you know it's a matter of
judgment
as to when a recession begins and ends
but you know
we lost uh millions tens of millions of
jobs in march and april and then we got
lots of those jobs back in may and june
when businesses reopened and so we went
from you know big declines persistent
broad-based declines in economic
activity that's a recession
to to growth of course having said that
the script is still being written here
we're still in the pandemic
oh you know things could go off the
rails uh and so we could start
backtracking again and if that's the
case then
then i'll be wrong the recession didn't
end in april it'll you know be a much
longer
recession right and we have the the one
big report that i've heard the president
talk about it's going to come out
not too far before the election is that
report on economic growth gdp for the
third
quarter so what do you what do you think
that we are going to see
oh it'll be a big gain i mean we
obviously had a huge loss in the second
quarter when businesses
shut down the pandemic first hit and
everyone was very nervous and was
self-quarantining so the economy
was down i think was just over 30
percent in an annualized rate
so we're going to get a big bounce back
in q2 and that reflects all those
business reopenings at the beginning of
the quarter
and so it'll be up you know 25 30
percent
uh but you know since june early july
the economy has kind of gone sideways
here you know it's growing but barely so
we'll get a big number for q3 but that
belies the kind of flat flatlining and
growth
we've experienced since you know there
are some things that are that are hard
to gauge
i mean you're an economist so you deal
with all these there's so many layers to
to to the economy in different numbers
and measures like
for instance we have a housing boom
going on sales going through the roof we
have low mortgage rates we have consumer
confidence that came out for september
better than august by far
better than economists like you had
expected the stock market has recovered
a lot of the losses over the summer that
it had in the springtime
so i know there's a lot of bankruptcies
and small businesses that have closed
forever but then you have this side so
how do you
put it all together yeah there's a lot
of cross currents uh i mean
in particular this economy you've got
some real winners and you've got some
real losers
uh you mentioned a couple of the winners
housing is the the one part of the
economy that has surprised me the most
uh you know with record low mortgage
rates below three percent
uh with the fact that uh we came into
this uh
a pandemic with a shortage of affordable
housing
and then this shift in preferences you
know people now want
to live in single-family homes more
removed from you know big urban centers
all that's kind of can come together and
cause the housing market to boom
but you know you know on the other side
of the commercial on the other side of
the real estate market the commercial
real estate market is
you know really struggling absorption is
way down for all for all kinds of space
retail hotels
office space and prices are down
as well transactions are down so it
really depends on which part of the
economic elephant you touch
you get a very different picture but
bottom line if you kind of put it all
together and
net out all the cross currents it's an
economy that
that's growing but but struggling to to
grow
you know you saw that yelp report that
came out it was like march through april
something like 72
000 businesses small businesses closed
permanently
the pandemic is really done real damage
to mom and pop
retailers smaller businesses in the
accommodation
leisure industry recreational industries
transportation health care and so it's
it's really been hard on small business
and that goes back to the point about
which part of the elephant you touch i
mean if you look at large
companies particularly the bigger
uh multinational companies they're doing
fine no problem
you know those are companies that are
benefiting from
the failures that are occurring at
smaller businesses and the small
businesses are
are really really struggling so and then
you have a few you know retailers that
have had
you know a lot of retail bankruptcies
you know certainly department stores
clothing stores took it on the chin
but then you have target walmart did
fine because they were open the whole
time
yeah exactly so the big guys are
benefiting from the the pain and
suffering of the small guys are taking
market share
and retail is the best example of that
but that dynamic is playing out lots of
other industries
and by the way dave that's one reason
why the stock market is doing so well
because the
companies that are the winners the big
guys they're the publicly traded
companies that are in the equity market
there's one thing in this economic
recovery republicans and democrats
agree on the federal reserve chairman
has said very very clearly that we need
an additional stimulus package
10 000 small businesses out there that
are talking about 36 percent could shut
down
if they don't get extended money that is
house minority leader kevin mccarthy you
heard congressman
john garamendia democrat first both
sides blame each other for the impasse
that dates back to may
when the house passed a bill to provide
another 3 plus
trillion dollars in corona financial aid
senate republicans said that was way too
much now there have been attempts to
compromise
the new house proposal unveiled this
week is 2.2
trillion dollars republicans want nearly
a trillion less
and speaker nancy pelosi and treasury
secretary steve mnuchin have been
talking the past few days trying to work
something out
what does economist mark sandy think we
need you know if i were king for the day
i'd go big
because there's a still the pandemic is
still on there's a lot of uncertainty
the economy's still struggling we want
to get to the other side of this and get
back to full employment as fast as
possible
interest rates are at zero so if you
were going to borrow money to
finance something you would do it now so
i would go big
so you know the president has been
talking about a one and a half trillion
dollar package
that's what i would go for or something
like that you know some money
uh for additional unemployment insurance
another round of stimulus checks more
money for small businesses through the
paycheck protection program
and i do think state and local
governments need help because if they
don't get it
they're going to start cutting jobs and
programs and that's going to be a direct
hit to the economy in the not too
distant future so that is such a big
political football though that
particular element they can't agree on
that one because republicans keep saying
they're not going to bail
out bad democrat-run states and cities
yeah and i'm a little perplexed by that
because the fiscal problems are evident
coast-to-coast it's not a
deep problem or in our problem it's a
problem uh you know and these are
critical jobs these are teachers of fire
police
the emergency responders you need them
at any time but particularly in a crisis
like this so
i am perplexed by that argument but you
know that's the argument that has kind
of won the day so far and we're not
getting that package so
i do think the risks to the this this
fragile recovery are
are rising and we could see some real
problems but towards the end of the year
beginning of next
all right now we talked to you back in
2019
seems like forever ago pre-pandemic it's
so hard to remember anymore
but we talked to you you have these
models that help you try to predict who
might win the election based on
your different economic models at the
time you thought things looked very good
for president trump
how do you think it looks now are those
models still in play or no uh it's very
close but it had the results have
flipped as you as you mentioned
uh trump was hands down the winner under
typical turnout
you know back when we chatted i guess
about a year ago when we first unveiled
these models
uh now uh biden would win
but it's uh razor thin again under
typical turnout
and uh uh pennsylvania is the key suite
this
key swing state and that's where i live
i'm a i was
raised here in pa and we've done
you might find this interesting we've
done a fair amount of work at a county
level to
identify which counties are most
important in each state
and the key county is chester county
that david that's exactly where i live
chester county so i joke that
this election probably revolves around
my wife and
we need to watch her very carefully so
in each state that are battleground
states uh there are how many counties do
you think really could
the whole election could rest on those
results yeah
just a half a dozen that's it i mean
it's this bizarre isn't it i mean
wait a minute you're breaking a whole
election down to a half dozen counties
i'm telling you yeah and it's probably
not many communities in those counties
so you know if you're you know in the
trump or biden campaign you need to
be focused like a laser beam on these
and they are if you see where the
candidates are going
they're going exactly where you know the
models say they should be going they're
going to
you know scranton pennsylvania or you
know outside of milwaukee
or you know in in michigan
these are the key swing communities
that'll determine how this election goes
the economy
in the next month does that
are we going to get enough information
to help the president make his case or
hurt the president the next month or no
no i think this is uh the die has been
cast here
at this point i mean the only thing that
can kind of throw a wrench into
everything is
the stock market right i mean the
president has shown a laser beam
a light on the on the equity market
that's his kind of
real-time report card so you know if
that headed south in a big way
or headed north in a big way that may
swing some
some voters minds but you know other
than that no i
at this point i think people's minds
have largely been made up and they
they have a pretty good sense of what
their own finances are and they've
connected the dots back to the election
so
uh i i think uh hard to imagine what
would
would uh swing the election at this
point mark zandy chief economist moody's
analytics resident of one of the most
important counties
in america thanks very much for joining
us
anytime dave thank you so much
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
rachel
campos duffy what's on your mind
feminists have an amy coney barrett
problem
for the next 30 days amy coney barrett
president trump's nominee for the
supreme court seat left vacant
by justice ruth bader ginsburg's death
will be the most talked about woman in
america
her life both professional and personal
will be under a flaw-enhancing magnifier
the kind every woman detests every
decision parrot has made will be sliced
and diced by
political operatives hoping to land a
knockout
nomination killing punch barrett is
unquestionably qualified
she graduated number one in her notre
dame law school class
eventually winding up as a clerk on the
supreme court for judge antonin scalia
students colleagues and former
professors all agree
that she is as brilliant as she is kind
generous and humble in short she has the
perfect intellect and temperament
for this all-important lifetime
appointment
as america gets a front row seat to the
life and times of judge amy coney
barrett
a lot of fair-minded women will conclude
that her journey
looks a lot like feminism to them
call it conservative feminism if you
like but
this feminist rebrand may prove a lot
more desirable
to everyday american women who harbor
more hope
for love marriage sex and kids
even lots of them than woke feminist
thought leaders think is possible
or even reasonable but wait
how could a pro-life catholic mom of
seven become the new face of feminism
and how dare she get married and start a
family in her twenties
how provincial to refuse to abide by a
socially and environmentally acceptable
number of children
it wasn't supposed to be this way the
feminist icon torch
was supposed to be passed to hillary
clinton but she fell
short in 2016.
clearly amy coney barrett is operating
at a higher intellectual and
professional level
than the vast majority of women
nonetheless
her life serves as a model to those of
us seeking an alternative to the
constraints of feminism
barrett broke all the rules in the
feminist playbook fully aware of her
exceptional academic and legal talents
she didn't take the predictable
high-powered law firm
route she went back to south bend to the
catholic community she knew and loved
to teach and raise babies she followed
her heart
investing early in the things that last
marriage
family and a deep and active spiritual
life
it takes courage faith to build a full
personal life
when the world is telling you that you
are squandering your talents by dividing
your time and energy
on diapers carpools and the quotidian
work of family life
liberals seem to be slowly if not
begrudgingly
coming to terms with the fact that amy
coney barrett is more likely than not
to replace their beloved and iconic ruth
bader ginsburg
the notorious rbg soon
feminists will also have to contend with
the fact that acb
will be an icon in her own right
tempering the excesses of feminism
and offering women the cultural
validation that feminism denied them
she is not a victim of the patriarchy
she is the product of her choices
and she reminds women who want to be
mothers that there are miles of space
between june cleaver and barbara walters
to land on
president trump should be commended for
recognizing the value of including the
voice of a mom with young children
on the most important court in the land
it sends a powerful message
about what our country can and should
value
the things that last
this is rachel campos duffy fox news
contributor and host
of moms on fox nation
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
fox news radio on demand on the fox news
app download the app
and just click listen when you swipe
left you can listen to your favorite fox
news talk shows live swipe right for the
latest fox news radio newscasts on
demand
fox news radio and the fox news app
download it today
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes